[Applaudissements]
oh
bonjour
c'est devenu notre temps est un endroit
où il faut pas non
dans le vin un
rabat où je dors ah oui tu dois mais tu
sais ponctuelles et j'ai payé en plus
vous avez même si j'ai payé aux mecs du
camping
il m'a dit leur emplacement numéro 8
je m'arrange chocolat doucement
doucement j'ai mis deux heures à la
montée déjà non mais moi il me faudrait
mieux tu peux ajouter un os oui oui
attendez attendez attendez à temps
ensemble oui ou non
laissez moi dormir encore une heure ou
deux on vous a dit quoi on nous a dit
vous allez vous voulez mais s'il faut
pas les couloirs toi que tu veux jouer
en solo alors moi je veux pas être gens
qui viennent jouer à côté de ma tante en
sortez d'ici maintenant jusqu'à présent
on parle très gentiment peuple autrement
si oui
autrement comment ça autrement on peut
te sortir à côté aux cubains tu as
compris à la criée pas j'ai mal au crâne
non mais ho
pin sapin on m'avait dit que les corses
étaient sympas mais oui mais on ne sait
pas mais quand même tu voudrais pas
remonter trop china mobile on nettoie
bas ça c'est pas de refus parce que là
c'est qu'est ce que c'est dur par terre
je vais pas pour le voir je sors je lis
bien joli mais je l'aimais de sackey
je m'en vais je m'en vais je m'en
voudrais que ça veut dire
au faire moins de bruit s'il vous plaît
je n'arrive pas à dormir
ou
non non non non non non non non non je
connais non
moi je fais moi après hop
[Musique]